by the way has anyone got whoa okay Drew
just fell through my
Decker yeah can I ask you a question
yeah sure is there any possible way that
I could go inside your apartment you
want to look at my apartment by the way
I'm such a fan of yours what does it
look like where you live I'm excited to
show you we're about to find out oh my
God I'm so
excited that's pretty much the tour but
I would like to show you one more thing
okay yeah it's outside okay yeah I have
a I have a cold punch and I was curious
if you would how the hell did you get
Plumbing up here I was curious if you
would like by the way has anyone got
whoa okay Drew just fell through my deck
actually I forgot to tell you that
there's a hole in the deck and you
almost died guess what I'm sorry I saved
myself I'm so sorry I feel bad I feel
bad so would you like to do a cold punch
I am ready you ready y okay we're going
to do rapid fire questions in the cold
Pune and we're not allowed to get out
until we answer all the
questions sounds good sounds like a plan
plan also you can just sit on the edge
if you want or you oh she's getting all
way celebrity crushes that did not
reciprocate you oh my God it's cold
Darth Vader Darth Vader weirdest thing
you've ever seen in a New York apartment
Drew Barrymore in my cold punch okay go
if you could change something about
yourself what would it be a bad internal
Voice have you ever gone on a date with
a stranger after touring their apartment
I'd prefer not to answer that question
most expensive thing in your
house
Rolex what's a celebrity's house that
you'd be scared to tour I would be
scared to tour um Martha Stewart's house
oh she would have words to say to you
what's the most important lesson you've
learned this year not to have a bad
internal toxic voice what's a dating
deal breaker dating deal breaker yes
they have too many red flags yeah I
think that works yeah yeah oh what's
your best celebrity kiss Andrew rynolds
last week on the
show I he doesn't play for my team but
you know it was good okay name 20 Fruits
name 20 Fruits yes banana pomegranate
Apple kiwi strawberry blueberry
raspberry C quat melon is that fruit
tomato is it potato fruit no no avocado
uh uh uh uh Co no coconut is that fruit
I don't know let's just say it is
pretend it is Clementine clementine
orange wow we're totally just Frozen
stuck uh apple apple
yeah how many is that is anyone counting
is that 20 that's a 14 uh uh uh uh
what's another fruit what's another
fruit cherry cherry cherry um poison
Berry poison Berry raspberry Blackberry
uh you said raspberry already I said
raspberry already grape grape prun
date
woo we did it good job feels good you
feel great now I do feel a little
euphoric oh my God this is how you start
your day yeah every day well that's a
real thanks Drew thanks for coming to my
[Music]
apartment